Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: John Ockey
"Non esistono più le mezze stagioni".
"È intelligente, ma non si applica".
"Si stava meglio quando si stava peggio".
"La matematica non è un'opinione".
"Ai tempi nostri,
ci si divertiva con poco".
"Sono sempre i migliori,
quelli che se ne vanno".
Ci sono luoghi comuni che, ogni anno,
vengono visitati da milioni di persone.
Iniziare questo talk
dicendo che stiamo vivendo
la sesta distruzione di massa,
quella che forse segnerà la nostra fine,
ne sarebbe un altro.
E quindi non lo faccio -
anche se l'ho appena fatto...
È che noi viviamo di contraddizioni,
e poche volte facciamo
quello che davvero vorremmo fare.
È necessario qualcosa,
o qualcuno, per risvegliarci.
Nel mio caso è successo questo:
una mattina, aprendo gli occhi,
ho assistito a un'alba bellissima.
Mentre sorgeva, il sole ha iniziato
a illuminare enormi strutture artistiche.
Ero al "Burning Man",
nel mezzo del deserto del Nevada,
un festival che ha più il sapore
di un esperimento sociale,
un sogno collettivo,
un luogo dove migliaia di persone
collaborano alla creazione
di queste gigantesche installazioni.
Il mio lavoro mi porta spesso in America:
ed è proprio lì, in America,
che ho assistito alla rinascita
di alcuni quartieri periferici
grazie alla forza rigenerativa
della street art.
Winwood Art District, a Miami,
ne è un esempio lampante.
Pensate che fino agli anni 2000
era un quartiere industriale periferico,
pieno di magazzini
e ben poco raccomandabile.
Ma proprio in quegli anni,
l'associazione Primary Flight
decise di creare in quest'area
un "open air museum",
ed invitò artisti
provenienti da tutto il mondo
a decorare i muri delle warehouse
con le loro opere.
Oggi, Winwood è il più grande
street art museum del mondo.
Io sono una sognatrice,
e l'America mi ha insegnato
che tutto è possibile.
Quindi mi sono chiesta:
ma perché non portare questo sogno qui,
in Italia, nel mio paese?
E a pensarci bene,
io una tela già ce l'avevo.
Questo edificio,
che è bruttino, lo ammetto,
ma l'ha costruito il mio bisnonno,
ed è arrivato a me
dopo la perdita di mio padre.
L'uomo che mi ha insegnato
ad amare il mare, a scalare le montagne,
lo stesso uomo che mi ha detto
di inseguire i miei sogni,
e che per farlo c'è bisogno
di costanza e determinazione.
Perché i sogni nel cassetto svaniscono,
e si trasformano i rimpianti.
Ecco, più lo guardavo,
più capivo che quel muro
poteva essere la tela perfetta
che avrebbe potuto lanciare
un messaggio a me caro.
Ma ero sola, e non avevo
la più pallida idea di come fare.
Un giorno, la mia insegnante di yoga
mi disse che per la religione induista
l'universo è perfetto,
che c'è equilibrio in tutto.
E che quando abbiamo un desiderio,
ed agiamo per realizzarlo,
l'universo ci asseconda, ci risponde.
Così, un'estate scoprii l'esistenza
di queste pitture magiche,
in grado di mangiare lo smog,
depurando l'area dall'88,8%
dell'inquinamento presente.
Nella stessa estate conobbi
la mia attuale vicepresidente,
una donna pratica e sognatrice
allo stesso tempo,
ed una brillante project manager.
L'universo stava rispondendo,
i tasselli si stavano inserendo
nel modo giusto.
Di lì a poco andai a New York,
e conobbi, sempre per caso,
Federico Massa, in arte Iena Cruz,
un artista già noto per la sua sensibilità
verso le tematiche ambientali.
Lui era l'anello mancante.
Gli raccontai del mio progetto,
lui accolse la sfida, venne a Roma
e di lì a poco mi mandò il primo bozzetto.
Così ho deciso di fondare
una no profit, "Yourban 2030",
per utilizzare il linguaggio
universale dell'arte
al fine di sensibilizzare
sull'importanza e sull'urgenza di agire
nei confronti delle tematiche ambientali.
E su quel muro, un tempo
solo del mio bisnonno,
in 21 giorni ha preso vita
"Hunting Pollution",
che per me rappresenta
la sintesi perfetta tra arte e tecnologia.
(Video)
Aldo! Scendi che ti vedo,
mi si è rotto il collo!
[Scoprite il più grande
green murale d'Europa]
[Un'opera di Iena Cruz]
(Applausi)
Avevamo realizzato il più grande
green murale d'Europa,
un'opera da Guinness,
1.000 metri quadri di murale.
"Hunting Pollution"
è in grado di assorbire l'inquinamento
prodotto da 80 veicoli, in un giorno.
È come piantare 30 alberi ad alto fusto.
E tutto questo grazie alla pittura
che abbiamo scelto per questo progetto,
una pittura a base acqua,
totalmente naturale,
antibatterica e anti smog.
Questa pittura agisce in modo molto simile
a quello della fotosintesi
clorofilliana delle piante.
Sì, perché a contatto con la luce
genera un processo fotochimico
attraverso il quale cattura
le particelle inquinanti
e le trasforma in sali innocui.
La poetica dietro "Hunting Pollution"
è un invito a riflettere
sulle azioni contaminanti
che l'uomo ha sull'ambiente.
Raffigura un airone multicolore,
una specie in via d'estinzione,
che caccia la sua preda
in un mare fortemente inquinato.
È in piedi su un barile di petrolio;
ormai è il suo habitat,
e delle gocce nere cadono su di lui,
in contrasto con quelle bianche.
L'airone è ignaro che quella preda
possa essere contaminata,
e quindi per lui letale.
E se ci pensate bene,
anche noi ignoriamo il pericolo
che corriamo ogni giorno
quando facciamo la cosa
più naturale del mondo:
respirare.
il 90% della popolazione mondiale
respira aria fortemente inquinata;
l'inquinamento coinvolge
nove persone su dieci in tutto il mondo,
mietendo sette milioni di vittime l'anno,
una ogni cinque secondi.
In Italia, su una popolazione
di 60 milioni di abitanti,
abbiamo 38 milioni
di veicoli in circolazione,
e 90.000 morti l'anno
riconducibili proprio
all'inquinamento atmosferico.
Eppure, continuiamo a disboscare.
Sapete quanti alberi dovremmo piantare,
per avere una riduzione significativa
dell'anidride carbonica?
Circa 10 milioni di chilometri quadrati,
pari più o meno all'estensione del Canada.
Gli indiani d'America dicono
che non ereditiamo la terra
dai nostri padri,
ma la prendiamo in prestito
dai nostri figli.
Io non sono ancora madre,
eppure una domanda mi perseguita:
ma cosa diremo ai nostri bambini?
Che non dipendeva da noi?
Che era un problema
al di fuori della nostra portata?
O insegneremo loro a sognare,
ad avere speranza,
ad agire per realizzare quei sogni,
per concretizzare quella speranza?
Qualche giorno fa ho ricevuto un'e-mail,
e ho il piacere di condividerla con voi:
"Gentilissima Veronica, mi chiamo Tommaso,
sono uno studente di Terni e ho 14 anni.
Ho visto in televisione
quello che ha fatto a Roma:
beh, io voglio proporre il mio palazzo,
che è in una città fortemente inquinata.
Abbiamo l'acciaieria ed un inceneritore:
Dio solo sa quello che respiriamo,
infatti sono nato con l'asma.
Ci sono alcuni giorni
che la mattina, quando si va a scuola,
non si riesce a respirare.
Per giunta, il nostro Comune,
in un'intera via,
ha fatto tagliare tutti gli alberi.
Ho visto che voi, con la pittura,
riuscite a cambiare l'aria:
mi piacerebbe che lei,
o chi lavora per lei,
dipingesse il mio palazzo,
che è in centro,
in una zona molto trafficata,
anche per far capire
ai grandi che comandano
che anche noi giovani abbiamo un cervello,
e che forse per il nostro futuro
vogliamo di più.
E se siamo su questa Terra,
dobbiamo curarla il più possibile.
Spero che mi risponda. Grazie, Tommaso".
Ecco: la mia nuova sfida,
il mio nuovo sogno,
è quello di concretizzare
progetti come questo.
Sto immaginando persone disposte
a donare le facciate dei loro edifici,
artisti disponibili a lavorarci sopra
ed un'operazione di crowdfunding
capace di coinvolgere tutti,
come possono, a partecipare.
Per sentirsi parte di un cambiamento,
di una metamorfosi,
perché quei muri e quelle opere
siano davvero di tutti.
Immagino un grido fatto di colori,
di un pensiero, di comunione.
Un mondo dove, guardando un muro,
si possa dire: "Questo è nostro",
perché questa è casa nostra.
E quindi no,
"Non esistono più le mezze stagioni",
"È intelligente ma non si applica",
"Si stava meglio quando si stava peggio",
"La matematica non è un'opinione",
"Ai tempi nostri
ci si divertiva con poco".
Perché concludere questo talk dicendo
che "Il futuro è nelle nostre mani"
sarebbe un altro luogo comune, l'ennesimo.
Ed io lo faccio perché è così.
(Applausi)